people are getting off the diet soda
I've talked about aspartame a lot people
have had it you know it's a it's a 61
billion dollar industry the diet soda
industry and you know what it's being
defeated by good old-fashioned water so
over the past year sales of non diet
sodas have declined 2.2% while diet
sodas have declined six point eight
percent ten years ago diet and non diet
soft drinks were the second most popular
food item today they've fallen to fourth
place behind sandwiches fruit and
vegetables and side effects of aspartame
include headaches mood alterations
hallucinations gastrointestinal problems
and actually much much more this strikes
me is really good I think all this
chemical stuff that we're putting in our
body that somehow in the 70s it became
okay to put just this evil stuff that
there's some connection to Donald
Rumsfeld and his family that they sort
of push this thing through the FDA and
like 72 yeah water water is gone and
that's just a basic knowledge would be
that water is good for you when you're
drinking chemicals in your nourishing
your body with chemicals are not
nourishing your body at all but I think
one of the things is people that drink
diet soda for a long time are under the
impression that diet so it is healthier
because the sugar is bad yeah so now all
these people are receiving more
information about diet soda really not
being that healthy so just people are
just dumping it and in this particular
article that you're referencing they
interviewed somebody who was at the gym
and saying he know first of all who
chugs a diet soda after going to the gym
but I guess they're making the point
that people used to be looking for
either sugary drinks or diet drinks as
part of their health you know have their
health care type thing for themselves
there's like oh I don't drink soda item
check features drink diet they're from
drinking nothing because the zero
calorie is misleading you know nature of
that but now people understand just know
better how about that we know better we
final and if you're drinking diet soda
you look like a we're actually think it
also could be as much as thinking what
do I look like drinking a diet soda I
think once you've more self-awareness
you realize like what does this even
mean what am i drinking I might it just
looks so outdated and weird and
chemically and gross I think people are
does like Walker's diet you know right
you know it's funny river so yeah but
your diet coke
right love diagonal adecco so what do
you think it's an open up you're putting
this stuff in your body why you do
whether it's no worse than coke well
okay so we can talk about let's talk
about high-fructose corn syrup just for
a second uh so we literally are putting
corn in our soda as I've said many times
because sugar if you buy coke in America
is too expensive so we put corn in our
in our soda instead as a matter of fact
if you want actual sugar in your coke
from America you've to buy a mexican
coke because they get the real stuff in
Mexico so it's an so you're saying it's
basically it's a trade or whether what
we wanted it the real stuff in next big
at the real stuff in Mexico that's all I
will do that at is another topic yeah so
it's good with it so yeah you're doing
it for the corn guys but really so for
you it's a trade-off of the fat and
you're okay putting high fructose corn
syrup which is awful it's Mercer a shin
moderation moderation and fitness and I
think those are what's really important
for health care in this country and walk
around and you'll see that we're not
quite following our following that lead
but I think it's important that people
eat healthier it's very expensive a part
of the problems if you have a family
people think I you know I agree we'll go
crazy on this for as anybody talking
about it because I have been in a
position where I've been almost like
dead broke and had no money and I've
been able to eat completely clean during
that time I think you can feed a family
completely on that same type of money I
understand it's 59 cents maybe to get
mcdonalds or get a burger but there are
ways to prepare meals for your family
that are that don't have that don't have
just msg that don't have high fructose
corn syrup but don't have all these
things in them and it's more responsible
for your health and it's not in
moderation when it comes to putting
chemicals that are actually poisonous in
your body and I'm not being hypocritical
I Sal of diet coke diet dr. pepper was
like my jam a 32 ounce diet dr. pepper
I'm circle k was like ah like it was
just a great guy pepper yeah it was
really great but I didn't look a girl so
he was dr. pepper I know but I mean I
had anxiety from it and I did have like
a little bit of stomach issues from it
and then I looked and do it and realize
what I was putting in my body and
stopped and I think that you know that I
think people will be there you go
Freddie
no there you carry the water with your
name it wasn't like that it's flask
shaped yeah that is very nicest future
is not it's a myth that it is more
expensive I think initially it might be
because you might have to retrain
yourself on how to prepare meals you
might have to figure out how to get your
kids to like things that are associated
with something they don't want to eat
but I don't think it is outrageously
more expensive one in the end you have
people with diabetes when you have
people that are so sick and can't even
afford the hospital bills with all these
things that are becoming directly
related to what people are putting their
body do you think people can heal
ourselves through healthy eating and I'm
an example of it so and trust me I love
taco bell and I love all these things
I'm not saying people shouldn't have
access to that be whatever you want yeah
we should have access to soda we should
have access to fast food access to
whatever you want but you will feel a
lot better cut that [ __ ] out yeah and
also uh first off McDonald there is no
such thing as a 59 sent hamburger
anymore it is a dollar and you know
every time we do a topic like this which
we do a lot and that's what everyone
says well fast foods cheaper and so your
if you tell people to cut it out you're
only hurting the lower economic people
however for the further let's say seven
dollars that you get a meal at
McDonald's you know like a number one or
whatever you could go to Trader Joe's
and get a sandwich and and actually a
juice or a water so I am I think that
argument I know it sounds good and I
know people are gonna get pissed in the
comments but it's I think that argument
sounds better than it actually is does
that does that jive we do families out
there with five kids that have a problem
and I go buy an orange for a dollar i'm
thinking if i had a family to support
how would I do it so there needs two
yeah I'm not saying it doesn't do it and
in bulk where families can eat healthier
Michelle Obama's done I think a
tremendous job in doing that in trying
to combat childhood obesity by promoting
healthy eating vegetable garden at the
White House there's a lot of symbolism
going on it's very important if 318
million of us are going to survive that
we become much more healthy and again
moderation yeah and and if you can have
some treats you can have that chocolate
cake but have a smaller piece and not
doing it every night yeah so not the
cakes hurting people as much as if the
chocolate cake is made through chemicals
I think if you make chocolate cake with
the ingredients and initially went into
making a chocolate cake you would have
people that are healthy and eating a
cake in moderation I think when you're
eating a chocolate cake that is
not even food you're going to be sick
with your moderation right so bringing
this back to diet soda which is made
with all this stuff there's just gonna
be a certain amount of people that are
gonna do this no matter what right like
is that just fair to say like there's
probably a good forty percent a man I'm
pulling that out uh out of thin air that
will just do it no matter how bad you
tell them it is gonna keep doing other
alternatives out there too when I was a
kid growing up that I don't know they're
not even any mountain dew then I don't
think so now you've got a huge variety
of of healthier drinks that the soft
drink companies are making look at
coca-cola Pepsi make water now flavor
their sabia and there's a god they at
all kinds of other sweeteners are
choices